13h32 je vous propose de démarrer nos
travaux
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons
donc les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête par l'audition de Messieurs
Mark shield président directeur général
et Thierry Hoffman directeur général et
pharmacien responsable des laboratoires
Delbert que je remercie de cette
mobilisée nous avons souhaité vous
entendre messieurs afin de mieux
comprendre comment fonctionne votre
entreprise décrite par le journal Le
Monde en décembre dernier je cite comme
le laboratoire pharmaceutique qui sauve
des médicaments en détresse nous avons
déjà procédé comme vous vous en doutez à
de nombreuses auditions et le prix trop
faible des médicaments dans notre pays a
souvent été pointée du doigt pour ses
effets délétères sur l'offre de soins et
ses conséquences dommageables pour la
vie des patients
je suis pour ma part assez choquée de
voir que si vous parvenez à maintenir
une production
d'amoxicilline injectable vous avez dû
renoncer à le commercialiser en France
compte tenu d'un prix de revient
supérieur au prix de vente c'est dire si
nous attendons votre éclairage sur la
régulation des prix des médicaments et
vos propositions pour la faire évoluer
dans un sauce plus conforme en tout cas
à l'intérêt des Français par ailleurs le
gouvernement a engagé une politique de
relocalisation destinée à garantir notre
souveraineté sanitaire concept encore un
peu flou il faut bien le dire dans les
exemples de soutien reste à ce jour peu
nombreux mais cette politique ne doit
pas se résumer au retour sur le sol
national ou au moins européen de la
production de principes actifs la
souveraineté sanitaire passe évidemment
par le maintien en France de la
production des médicaments qui sont
encore fabriqués c'est pourquoi nous
attendons que vous que vous nous
expliquiez comment vous parvenez à
relancer la production de médicaments
orphelins ou mtid MITM indispensable à
la santé de nos patients dans les airs
thérapeutiques que couvrent vos produits
alors ce n'est pas vous faire un jure
que de dire que la taille des
laboratoires d'Albert est encore
relativement modeste mais la forte
croissance de votre chiffre d'affaires
et le soutien que vous ont récemment
apporté vos actionnaires qui comprennent
aussi bien tout le monde investissement
qu'une mutuelle témoigne de l'intérêt de
votre modèle économique nous sommes par
conséquent donc impatient d'en savoir
davantage et de comprendre comment ce
modèle pourrait être décliné à d'autres
médicaments avant d'aller plus loin je
vais vous céder la parole donc pour pour
un bref propos introductif puis madame
Laurence Cohen ici présent donc
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions comme vous l'aurez compris
notre commission d'enquête en temps
obtenir des réponses étayées à des
questions assez précises
je précise également que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat fera d'ailleurs
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié et
avant de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête est passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le jure
je
le jure messieurs shield et Hoffman donc
vous avez prêté serment monsieur shield
vous avez la parole
merci la Présidente nous avons préparé
un petit propos liminaire et comme comme
vous l'avez dit c'est vrai que Delbert
est une création relativement récente
puisque ça a été créé en fait en 2003
mais repris par moi-même et Thierry
Hoffman en 2014 on s'est intéressé en
fait pour rien vous cacher on est deux
anciens d'industrie pharmaceutiques donc
on a vécu l'industrie pharmaceutique de
l'intérieur il faut savoir que cette
industrie on en pourra en reparler sur
certains aspects mais on a voulu
d'Albert différent d'Albert on l'a voulu
sans promotion d'abord et pour aller
vers une production de produits
consommés sans promotion on s'est
intéressé à des produits connus et
médicalement utile donc dès le départ
notre positionnement a été de
s'intéresser aux médicaments connus qui
était en train de disparaître
pourquoi pour une raison basique et
simple basique ça veut dire Thierry et
moi nous avions nos propres économies
pour commencer l'histoire de delberg on
a mis en 400000 euros sur la table pour
commencer l'ensemble de des opérations
de l'activité de Dilbert pour arriver
jusqu'en
2020-2020 ou les fonds d'investissements
ainsi que la BPI il faut le souligner a
considéré que dAlbert est une belle
histoire qu'il fallait soutenir soit par
des prêts soit par des investissements
notre mission c'était de retrouver des
produits et assez rapidement on en a
trouvé en déshérence je dis bien en
déshérence des produits pour lequel
les Big Pharma ne voulaient pas
continuer la
production
c'est multi factoriels ce jeu d'arrêter
la production pour les Big Pharma on
pourra y revenir sur sur différents
le premier c'est un produit dans la
maille de Vaquez et pour lequel nous
sommes arrivés à un moment je le prends
comme exemple maladie rare produit en
France mais arrêté par un laboratoire
américain
dont le prix de remboursement était aux
alentours des 8 € par l'argent dont le
prix de production est passé assez
rapidement aux alentours des 25 26 euros
nous avons demandé à l'époque au CEPS de
prendre en considération ces prix de
rembourse de production pardon et ils
nous ont octroyé une augmentation de
prix sur ce produit à 46 euros il faut
savoir que les alternatives à se
produire aujourd'hui les innovations ce
qu'on appelle les innovations valent
4000 euros le coût de traitement mensuel
c'est à dire que pour nous de défendre
un produit qui fait 46 euros coût de
traitement mensuel versus 4000 euros
savait du sens d'autant plus que les
gens
traités par ce produit c'était plein
auprès des hématologues qui s'étaient
plaints auprès de du ministère de la
Santé et ce voyez aussi avoir une
couverture médiatique concernant ce
produit ça a été le premier le deuxième
pour rien vous cacher ça a été
extensible dans quel le traitement de
référence mondial traitement minute de
la syphilis et c'est comme ça qu'on a
commencé donc on couvre aujourd'hui
15 produits quasiment la moitié en
infectiologie parce que l'infectiologie
est totalement délaissée on voit qu'il y
a quelques nouveautés mais les modèles
proposés aux nouveautés dans dans
l'antibiothérapie sont toujours à
trouver donc il y a des problèmes entre
guillemets de modèles aujourd'hui on
commercialise nos produits aussi bien en
France où on fait à peu près 65% de
notre chiffre d'affaires mais aussi
dans cinq pays européens en direct et
dans une
syncotropéie européen à travers des
partenaires donc les prix comparés de
pays en pays c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut
discuter ensemble en effet on n'a pas
des mêmes comportements de pays en pays
sur des produits anciens je dis bien
mais il va falloir qu'on distingue et
assez rapidement je laisserai la parole
à Thierry ce que nous on appelle ancien
de ce que on appelle mature de ce qu'on
appelle un ITM et ce qu'on pourrait
enfin appeler critique je pense que
c'est pas du tout le même type de
médicament et que aujourd'hui il faut
s'intéresser à ce que ce que deviendront
les médicaments critiques
[Musique]
ça fait 50 équivalent en plein en
sous-traitance en France et 50
équivalent en plein en sous-traitance
aussi en Europe
90% nos matières premières sont sourcées
en Europe et 100% de nos médicaments
sont fabriqués en Europe
90% des matières premières sont sourcées
en Europe et 100% des produits sont
fabriqués en Europe
50% à peu près en France
aujourd'hui on a repris 15 produits
auprès de Big Pharma il faut il faut le
dire et les raisons de rupture il y a
pas une seule raison de rupture c'est
pas le modèle économique c'est pas la
rentabilité uniquement qui est en cause
les abandons les a repris la plupart du
temps parfois avec des ruptures de
traitement comme extensible qui a duré 4
ans 4 ans sans extensible c'est
relativement long il y a d'autres
ruptures sur le sur lequel on est
intervenu plus tôt on est sauveteur dans
le sens où on essaie de ressusciter dans
certains cas mais on préfère réanimer
c'est-à-dire que s'il y a encore un
stock à pouvoir racheter chez les chez
les fabricants ça nous intéresse que
comme ça le marché peut être plus fluide
donc l'important c'est d'anticiper ce
qui va se passer l'anticipation pour
nous est important et on travaille en ce
moment sur un sur un sujet qui rit
et les équipes sont à 100% là dessus sur
un antibiotique à visible pédiatrique
qui savait en rupture et qui pourrait
entreimer faire l'objet de rupture
l'année prochaine si on ne fait rien et
là il y a encore des choses à faire on
pourra en discuter
le dernier point que je tiens à
souligner c'est que nous traitons
aujourd'hui en des populations cibles de
nos médicaments soient 500 patients à
200 000 patients donc c'est c'est pas
des énormes volumes voilà et au total on
a aujourd'hui traité 500000 européens
tous les ans qui bénéficient notre
traitement et ça je peux vous dire on en
est fier
merci
je propose de poursuivre ces échanges et
de prendre la parole monsieur Hoffmann
merci Madame la vice-président peut-être
pour
illustrer quelques points
au cours de précédentes audition on a
beaucoup parlé de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur ou dans ces
auditions
j'ai cru comprendre que beaucoup
pensaient que c'était la NSM qui fixait
la liste des médicaments
majeurs et ben non ce sont les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
et je suis le premier surpris de voir
que il n'y ait pas d'homogénéité dans le
traitement de ces médicaments pour vous
dire il y a certains produits que nous
déclarons nous comme majeur et que
d'autres génériqueurs ne déclarent pas
comme majeur avec toutes les
conséquences que ça sur les gestion de
stock les pénuries qu'on pourrait avoir
et le traitement de ces pénuries donc
sachez qu'il y a à peu près 7000
médicaments qui sont définis par
l'industrie pharmaceutique et par les
labos eux-mêmes comme médicament
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur
il faut bien faire la différence entre
ceux qui sont importants et les
médicaments critiques ils se sont deux
choses différentes il y a des
médicaments qui sont importants dans
l'arsenal thérapeutique du médecin
généraliste ou du médecin spécialiste
mais il y a des médicaments qui sont qui
remplaçables et ces deux choses
extrêmement différentes nous au sein de
notre labo on sait toujours attaché à
essayer de trouver des médicaments pour
lesquels il y avait pas d'alternatives
et de remettre sur le marché en
produisant en Europe c'est même
médicament mais on ne peut pas traiter
7000 médicaments comme de 200
médicaments et c'est ça que je pense que
l'administration a beaucoup de mal à
comprendre
c'est que le prix du médicament est
important bien sûr parce que
redévelopper au jour d'aujourd'hui avec
les normes de qualité que ce qui nous
sont demandés ça coûte très cher que on
ne peut pas commercialiser un médicament
à perte vous me parliez tout à l'heure
de xylomac
d'amoxicilline que nous avons racheté
donc à GSK produit qui s'appelait
Clamoxyl injectable produit qui était en
ville et également à l'hôpital en boîte
de une unité lorsque nous avons repris
ce médicament là en toute honnêteté
c'est l'Agence du Médicament belge qui
nous a demandé de reprendre ce
médicament parce que il y a une seule
amoxicilline injectable en Belgique
et donc nous avons le prix à JSK c'est à
eux-mêmes mais qui était une amie même
européenne donc nous avons racheté pour
tous les territoires
il se trouve que
ce produit
était vendu en France ou evendu en
France à 1,09 l'unité ce qui est
absolument ridicule lorsqu'on a demandé
au ministère de l'économie belge
d'augmenter le prix de 1 euro on l'a
obtenu en six semaines aujourd'hui ça
fait presque deux ans que nous avons
demandé au CEPS une augmentation de 1
euro et c'est d'autant plus ridicule que
aujourd'hui ce médicament s'il était sur
le marché en ville permettrait
d'économiser des dizaines de milliers de
journées d'hospitalisation en effet
sachez que lorsqu'un patient en post-op
ont subi une infection ou en prévention
d'une infection on lui met une
couverture d'amoxicilline injectable
si il y avait de l'amoxicilline
injectable en ville il pourrait sortir
trois jours plus tôt
le coût pour la sécurité sociale ces
300.000 euros
le coût de dépenses de santé à l'hôpital
c'est des dizaines et des dizaines de
millions d'euros
donc c'est là qu'on arrive dans une
certaine absurdité c'est que le CEPS
juge sur des prix de médicaments
uniquement sur des primes médicament et
ne voient pas à côté le coût total que
représente à la société
l'absence d'un médicament sur le
territoire mais c'est pas la même
enveloppe c'est pas la même c'est pas la
même enveloppe mais non voilà pourquoi
nous avons demandé 2 euros il y a
maintenant plus de 18 mois au CEPS et
que nous sommes toujours on nous a
royalement proposé un euro 20 et en se
cachant derrière l'article 28
sur une interprétation personnelle de
l'article 28 on dit mais donnez-nous le
prix de l'amoxicilline quand GSK
commercialiser le produit comment il
revient prix il revient comment
voulez-vous qu'un laboratoire qui a
acheté un médicament puisse avoir le
détail analytique
du prix de revient industriel par le
vendeur surtout que le vendeur achète la
matière première à 112 donc nous sommes
dans l'impossibilité de donner le prix
du kilo d'amoxicilline par GSK et bien
uniquement pour cette raison le dossier
est bloqué depuis 18 mois et les
patients ne peuvent pas avoir le produit
donc vous voyez madame la
vice-présidente la ville n'est pas
toujours simple pour industriel
et quelquefois nous sommes confrontés à
des situations qui nous paraissent nous
totalement
absurde de la part de l'administration
et quelquefois il faut beaucoup de
courage pour se dire qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire avec le prochain produit à
développer parce que ça devient de plus
en plus compliqué les normes de qualité
sont dedans plus en plus lourdes pour
nous on nous demande d'aller chercher
des impuretés à des taux extrêmement bas
extrêmement bas tout ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent
si c'est pour avoir aucune
reconnaissance et lorsque sur un produit
comme l'amox icilline on fait on prend
deux sites de production en Europe pour
être certain de pas avoir de pénurie on
utilise deux sources de matières
premières dont notre principal en Europe
et que on a une administration en face
de nous qui est sourde c'est extrêmement
difficile à accepter
merci pour vos propos et témoignages je
vous propose donc d'écouter notre
rapporteur madame Laurence Cohen qui a
donc comme je vous l'avais expliqué une
série de questions
oui peut-être que la première question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est
finalement là où Monsieur Hoffman vous
avez vous avez terminé c'est sur le prix
des médicaments
effectivement on l'a vu lors de nos
différentes auditions c'est un problème
récurrent
avec plusieurs éléments à mettre en
lumière premier élément c'est l'opacité
totale c'est-à-dire que effectivement le
CEPS détermine un prix mais en tout cas
le commun des mortels on a absolument
pas de vision nous souhaiterions nous
pouvoir sur ce prix du médicament avoir
une idée sur le service médical rendu
réel
sur le le prix de revient de de la
production sur le respect des normes
environnementales et sociales parce que
c'est pas possible de mettre en
concurrence des entreprises je vais les
appeler vertueuses qui respectent les
normes et puis au même au même niveau
que celle qu'il ne respecte pas et
quatrième élément à prendre en compte
c'est à dire que toute entreprise qui
produit un médicament
doit en tirer un bénéfice si tout ça a
été clairement établi je pense et nous
pensons que déjà ça est mieux donc il y
a le problème de l'opacité mais il y a
aussi le problème en France
du fait que chaque année le Parlement
examine un nom d'âme
nous avons des approches suivant nos
bancs dans cette assemblée on va dire
différente sur sur l'ONDAM mais en
mettant ça de côté l'ondamment et est
une variable d'ajustement pour faire
faire des économies en gros à notre
système de santé et à l'intérieur de
cette enveloppe fermée
on joue pas nous mais bon dans
l'établissement des prix on va rogner
pardonnez-moi cette expression sur les
produits matures au profit des produits
innovants qui eux ne sont jamais en
rupture ou ou en pénurie donc on voit
bien là qu'il y a une limite et en même
temps si on est simpliste et que on se
dit bon bah c'est pas finalement c'est
pas compliqué on va augmenter les prix
et les choses vont s'améliorer on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas si simple que
ça puisque l'exemple que nous avons pu
constater lors de plusieurs de nos de
nos auditions c'est qu'en Suisse les
prix sont nettement plus élevés je pense
notamment aux antibiotiques et que la
Suisse a connu des pénuries très
importantes d'antibiotiques donc ça
n'est pas le seul facteur donc ça c'est
ma première question par rapport à cette
réflexion sur
le prix du médicament ensuite deuxième
question c'est suite aux propos
introductifs de de ma collègue
présidente Alexandra c'est quelle
sélection faites-vous parmi les dossiers
qui se qui atterrissent sur votre bureau
pour reprendre la formule qui a été
employée dans le monde troisième
question vous vous indiquez que sur
votre site les laboratoires d'Albert et
ça a été redit là aussi dans le dans les
propos introductifs commercialise des
médicaments en France et en Europe pour
le propre compte et aussi le compte de
tiers est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser justement ce que recouvre ces
deux
activités et leur part respectifs dans
votre chiffre d'affaires quelle est la
part de votre activité de production de
principes actifs
de fabrication de médicaments et de
commercialisation de spécialités
produite par d'autres laboratoires
ma quatrième question
c'est concernant les aides publiques
depuis votre création est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire de quelle aide publique
vous avez pu bénéficier est-ce que vous
avez sollicité des soutiens dans le
cadre de France relance et est-ce que
vous en avez bénéficié
ma cinquième question mais vous l'avez
vous l'avez évoqué on en revient
toujours à la fixation des prix
vous avez bien exprimé comment se
déroulait finalement les négociations
avec le CEPS mais
est-ce que le CEPS tient compte du
risque de disparition du médicament
produit par votre laboratoire puisqu'en
fait vous prenez effectivement vous
repêcher un certain nombre de
médicaments donc est-ce que ce facteur
ce critère de prise de risque est un
élément qui peut valoriser le prix du
médicament ou pas et quel est l'impact
de la clause de sauvegarde sur votre
activité est-ce que vous avez renoncé
par exemple à reprendre la production
d'un médicament contenu de son incidence
financière j'avoue que lors de nos
auditions la clause de sauvegarde est
beaucoup revenu enfin trois dernières
questions nous avons comme vous le savez
auditionner d'autres laboratoires avant
le vôtre et parmi ceux-là nous avons eu
un responsable qui nous a expliqué que
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament lui interdisait de mettre sur
le marché l'intégralité de sa production
et est-ce que vous êtes concerné par ce
type de contingentement c'est à dire que
à partir du moment où il y a des
tensions sur un médicament l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
contingente et donc dit au labo bah non
il faut donner que ça parce qu'il faut
réserver la suite etc est-ce que vous
êtes confronté vous aussi vous avez été
confrontés à ce même type de phénomènes
est-ce que vous êtes confronté au
phénomène des exportations parallèles
réalisées par des shortliners et si oui
qu'elle est finalement son impact sur
les sur votre activité et la dernière
question je crois que je dois en être à
9 questions qu'est-ce que
ouvre la politique de souveraineté
nationale pour vous
on dit qu'il faut
comment dirais reprendre une politique
de souveraineté nationale si on veut
si on veut régler ou en tout cas
commencer à régler ce problème de
tension de pénurie des médicaments
est-ce que vous vous en pensez puisque
en fait on vous additionne à la fois
pour avoir un état des lieux mais aussi
pour avoir des pistes puisque vous savez
que dans tout rapport d'une commission
d'enquête il y a un état des lieux mais
il y a aussi un certain nombre de
recommandations et qu'on se nourrit des
auditions que nous que nous faisons
passer pour effectivement les alimenter
et ensuite les les proposer donc voilà
les questions que je sais qui sont
nombreuses qui englobe beaucoup de
choses il y a un a certaines que vous
auquel vous allez pouvoir répondre
directement d'autres où vous aurez
peut-être besoin d'un peu plus de
réflexion mais vous savez que à l'issue
vous aurez un questionnaire et vous
pourrez nous répondre par écrit mais
disons que dans ce dans ce va-et-vient
c'est peut-être plus plus facile d'avoir
quand même un des débuts de réponse et
je vous remercie par avance et encore je
me suis retenu parce que j'avais le
double de questions à vous poser
donc 10 questions vous avez peut-être
une question bonus en plus
non
voilà on peut rester de nous trois
heures parce que c'est un sujet enfin
qui nous passionne honnêtement qui nous
passionne il faut il faut je vais
revenir à la notion d'opacité sur les
prix
c'est une opacité qui est passée opaque
que ça il y a une opacité peut-être
sur la difficulté de comprendre sur les
innovations comment sont construits les
prix mais si on regarde un petit peu le
l'ensemble de l'enveloppe elle est
constituée en effet de cette innovation
est constituée de générique elle est
constituée deux produits matures et de
produits orphelins aujourd'hui nous
notre vision c'est qu'il faudrait isoler
une une enveloppe entremet produit
critique qu'il faut qu'il faudrait pas
attendre
je vous explique pourquoi parce que les
prix
les prix quand Thierry et moi ont dépose
un prix auprès des autorités de santé en
France tout ce que vous demandez est
écrit est écrit noir sur blanc le prix
de la matière première toute la
décomposition est écrite
totalement les factures sont fournies
tout est transparent
voilà
entre nous il se place tout est
transparent
il y a une grille qui est fournie par le
CAPS qu'il faut renseigner précisément
il y a même les indirects il y a même
tout il y a tout on peut pas on peut pas
entre guillemets avoir plus d'éléments
que ça
ensuite
on parle des des prix des antibiotiques
des prix des antibiotiques c'est des
médicaments très anciens et sur lequel
80% aujourd'hui des des
usages sont sur des produits qui ont
plus de 40 ans les prix des
antibiotiques contrairement à ce qui
nous a été dit parfois c'est qu'il y a
des gains de productivité en 40 ans non
il n'y a pas de gain de productivité ça
n'existe pas c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui les gains de productivité on
les a fait ça a été historique c'est
pour ça qu'on est dépendant et de l'Inde
et de la Chine pour les produits
volumétriques
aujourd'hui vous savez qu'il y a une
usine en Chine qui a brûlé qui faisait
pibopipo
qui a brûlé deux ans de rupture
mondiales aujourd'hui il y a une seule
usine au niveau monde qui fait
amoxicilline acide clevelanic une seule
usine au monde donc quelque part les
gains de productivité c'est la
massification nous on travaille pas sur
de la massification
voilà
donc la transparence des prix c'est
aussi l'évolution de des prix des API
aujourd'hui on est dans une période
inflationniste extrêmement importante
très dangereuse pour notre santé
publique je prends un cas de figure qui
nous impacte directement le lithium le
lithium a fait une augmentation de la
matière première de 400% à cause des
voitures bien sûr mais ça nous impacte
le terralite pour paliter en France
c'est le prix le plus bas de toute
l'Europe et c'est un facteur 2 à 3 c'est
pas un produit récent
mais ça touche à peu près 150 000
Français traités par terralite
aujourd'hui
on a un risque direct de vente à perte
sur le terralic du fait de
l'augmentation de la pays l'augmentation
de l'API a eu lieu en 15 mois donc
comment répercuter tout ça sur la santé
c'est une des problématiques que l'on a
l'enveloppe de l'ONDAM est une enveloppe
globale vous le savez bien et je parle
aussi de la de la clause de sauvegarde
la clause de sauvegarde nous impacte
directement
le profit entre guillemets qu'on sort au
niveau de du CEPS un profit théorique
raboté par la dame
raboté parlons d'âme c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas la rentabilité
des Big Pharma loin de là
aujourd'hui il faut entre guillemets
considérer ça dans la discussion avec le
CEPS mais la lecture de la sauve de club
de sauvegarde est totalement impossible
donc aujourd'hui on est amené Thierry et
moi a décidé de ne pas s'intéresser à
tel ou tel dossier dont on sait le
besoin médical urgent et futur
on peut vous en citer certains
donc
le dernier point et je laisserai la
parole à Thierry pour le les aides
publiques ou c'est le short liner au vu
des volumes et des prix bas du
médicament non nous n'avons pas à faire
entre guillemets à des short liners sur
notre sur notre activité mais il faut
savoir que quand on reprend des AMM et
Thierry par les de reprises de
l'amoxicilline mais il faut savoir que
chaque pays du fait que ça soit des
enregistrements multinationaux plutôt
nationaux multiples
ils ont les mêmes des formulations
différentes de pays en pays
c'est à dire que une usine va faire une
formule pour la
l'Italie et une formule différente pour
la Tchéquie une formule différente pour
la France ce qui fait que les short
liners peuvent pas exporter c'est pas le
même produit
voilà parce que on arrive nous sur des
sur des produits très anciens
donc je vais laisser la parole sur les
aides publiques et sur le risque
sur les aides publiques on en a eu très
peu et
on a eu une aide qui a été extrêmement
précieux c'est le crédit pour recherche
le crédit pour recherche et honnêtement
sans le crédit pour recherche d'Albert
ne serait pas ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
alors attendez on parle pas de Somme
diabolique on parle de 300000 euros par
an mais lorsque vous débutez
c'est très précieux alors bien sûr on
essayait de viser travailler avec des
entreprises qui étaient accréditées au
CIR mais tout le monde n'était pas par
exemple lorsqu'on a travaillé ou
redéveloppement l'extensiline alors
l'excent Céline c'est une belle histoire
c'est les GI américain débarquent en 45
avec la pénicilline G
produit largement utilisé et abandonné
dans les années 70
aujourd'hui la pénicilline G ça reste
comme ce produit n'a plus utilisé depuis
30 ans un antibiotique sur lequel il y a
plus de résistance
donc c'est un produit qui est
extrêmement intéressant mais il a fallu
redévelopper de la fermentation en
Europe puisque nous vous voulions faire
un produit européen donc trouver un site
de fermentation en Europe je peux vous
dire c'est extrêmement compliqué donc on
a dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour ça et
on a trouvé un site de production après
en Italie tout ça c'est un million
d'euros sans aucune aide alors bien sûr
pour d'autres produits on a eu l'aide du
CIR mais c'est la seule aide que dont on
a bénéficié et depuis maintenant deux
ans trois ans ça tourne aux alentours
d'entre 50 et 100.000 euros mais pas
plus
donc
mais heureusement qu'on a eu le crédit
un projet et là je dois dire que la
France a été vraiment très pionnière
dans cette démarche et après suivi par
d'autres pays l'Espagne maintenant
complètement adopté ce processus
donc France relance on ne connaît même
pas ce que c'est
est-ce que le CEPS est sensible au
risque de disparition d'un médicament la
réponse est totalement non
le CPAS a toujours un peu tendance à
penser que l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'est comme l'industrie automobile et
l'industrie de l'informatique mais c'est
un milieu est un marché très différent
c'est pas parce que on est un vieux
produit c'est pas parce que on n'a pas
d'ASMR depuis réviser depuis des années
qu'on n'est pas important et aujourd'hui
l'amoxicilline injectable reste le
l'antibiotique majeur utilisé en Europe
et lorsqu'on entend de dire mais lorsque
vous avez acheté votre reprise avec
l'axo vous saviez pertinemment que le
produit serait vendu à perte donc ne
demandez pas au CEPS de rattraper cette
situation c'est d'autant plus dommage
que la France est le seul pays à voir
cet état d'esprit et je suis un peu déçu
en tant que citoyen français de voir que
dans tous les autres pays on a eu une
ouverture d'esprit bien plus large en
France
cause de sauvegarde
expliquer bien sûr mais je trouve ça
aussi inéquitable que les vieux produits
et là je parle aussi de tous mes
collègues et tous nos confrères qui au
sein de la milice ont des petites
entreprises comme les nôtres et qui sur
des produits importants commercialisés
produits qui se trouve amputé à la fin
de l'année par un montant qui est
totalement inconnu six mois avant
puisque la clause de sauvegarde dépend
en fait bien sûr de long terme mais de
la dépense que l'on ne connaît que un an
après et ça c'est très gênant pour
l'industriel
parce que ben on ne peut pas
provisionner ces sommes
et c'est quelque chose que je pense qui
n'est plus d'actualité et les montants
dont on parle d'ondam dans les années à
venir sont absolument délirants
puisqu'on parle non plus en centaines de
millions d'euros mais on parle en
milliards d'euros
une de vos questions madame la
rapporteur concernée aussi et la NSM
et la production
sur ce point là la NSM est sensible à la
production et en toute honnêteté on a eu
beaucoup de compréhension de la part de
la NSM
sur
les développements que l'on a fait
et on a toujours travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec des réunions à peu
près tous les deux mois trois mois pour
faire le point de où on était des
difficultés qu'on rencontrait et avoir
je dirais la vie de la NSM sur les
contrats et ça c'est extrêmement
appréciable puisque c'est une approche
qu'on retrouve plutôt à la FDA que en
Europe et je dois dire que la NSM a
toujours été d'un très grand support
pour Dilbert et on le remercie
juste un petit point puisque je reprends
sur la question 3
d'Albert travaille pour ses propres
produits et pour tiers on a on a
commencé entre guillemets notre activité
en prestation de service pour pouvoir
justement constituer finalement une
pelote de laine après session de service
étant l'exploitation la
pharmacovigilance et puis l'information
médicale on a commencé pour un petit
laboratoire allemand d'ailleurs qu'on
garde toujours par affection voilà qui
fait qui fait des produits
ophtalmologiques mais qui sont pas
vraiment présents chez nous après on a
hébergé par contre un gros industriel de
des génériques
avec qui on a essayé de porter une offre
vers les hôpitaux pour élargir justement
ce cette offre dans des produits
critiques donc des curare on a essayé on
a essayé de vendre pendant la période un
peu critique des cura on pourra vous en
reparler de de la mise entre guillemets
à l'écart de nos curare façon de parler
et donc ce laboratoire s'appelle Hikma
d'un laboratoire jordanien et on a
arrêté toute prestation pour lui
maintenant depuis un an et aujourd'hui
des activités portières représentent
inférieure à 1% de notre activité voilà
pour vous répondre à cette question 3
juste un autre un autre point puisque
j'ai été l'action la question 9 au
passage on parle de souveraineté
nationale oui c'est ça a été ça a été
notre objectif la souveraineté plutôt
européenne c'est à dire que on a bien
conscience et on est à la recherche on a
tout un direction industrielle chez nous
même si on soustraite la totalité de nos
activités il faut bien comprendre que on
recherche au maximum un premier temps
des usines en France qui seraient soit
en sous capacité mais qui serait en
capacité de produire le type de
médicaments ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est la complexité de fabriquer un
médicament c'est des usines spécialisées
c'est des fournisseurs spécialisés et
c'est des contrôles spécialisés
l'ensemble de ces de ces phénomènes là
prennent énormément de temps à être
déployés
quand on reprend une AMM
si on change un des éléments
c'est-à-dire soit la formule de départ
soit le fournisseur de matières
premières soit le fournisseur de
produits finis ça coûte à peu près
500.000 euros et 12 mois de travail si
vous en changez deux c'est 18 mois de
boulot et un million si vous en changer
trois c'est plus de deux ans de boulot
c'est ça qu'il faut et quand un
industriel arrête ce médicament
donc plus de 50% des cas c'est parce
qu'il y a un problème d'usine c'est
qu'il y a un problème de sécurité dans
l'usine ou de volumétrie dans l'usine
c'est pas un problème uniquement
économique les usines c'est entre
guillemets notre matière vivante pour
faire des médicaments et aujourd'hui on
peut pas comprendre non plus que
l'argent de l'État serve à subventionner
des usines vides
il y a des usines
non remplies prenez soin génie mémak
aujourd'hui le taux de remplissage c'est
10 15%
. 20% 30% maximum une usine qui tourne à
20 30% ne peut pas être rentable
pourquoi entre guillemets ces unes sont
pas remplies parce que
les pays les prix de revient industriels
seront plus chers chez elle qu'ailleurs
je reprends le terralite le terralite
est fabriqué en Slovaquie
on essaie de rapatrier en France voilà
est-ce qu'on a des subventions non on le
sait par envie nature citoyenneté
souveraineté
ça va coûter plus cher
mais ça sécurise entre guillemets
l'approvisionnement par rapport aux
hausses de prix sur l'électricité parce
qu'on a nous une protection sur le sol
électricité l'électricité à monter
cost of good montre
c'est un tas de sous-éléments qui font
que
ces médicaments s'arrêtent au bout d'un
moment la complexité fait que les Big
Pharma
tirés par des produits à plusieurs
milliards de chiffre d'affaires vont
plus s'intéresser à un produit qui fait
20 millions même si il est rentable même
si il est rentable
je vais vous demander avant de passer
la parole à mes collègues même la
présidente à s'en charger puisque
c'était elle qui qui organise la Réunion
mais vous dites si j'ai bien compris que
l'article 28 de l'accord cadre l'aime
CEBS n'est pas appliquée puisque je cite
lorsque une entreprise fait état d'un
risque important pouvant impacter la
production ou la commercialisation pour
l'une de ces spécialités répondant à un
besoin qu'on ne serait qui or qui ne
serait plus couverts au cas où elle
disparaîtrait du marché l'entreprise
peut demander la hausse du prix en vue
de permettre son maintien sur le marché
ça c'est l'article 28 de l'accord cadre
l'aime ceps donc si j'ai bien compris
cette cette ça n'est pas appliqué
alors on peut pas dire ça parce que cet
article si vous en avez sorti un extrait
et l'extrait est plus est un peu plus
grand puisque il parle dans cet extrait
là de comparable
de comparable que ça vous pouvez
commencer ce travail de révision de prix
s'il n'y a pas de comparable
mais les comparable ils existent
toujours
directement indirectement il y a des
classes thérapeutiques si vous parlez du
terralide par exemple les 150 000
Français il y a des comparables il y a
des antiiques par exemple c'est
comparables mais c'est pas comparable
pour le pour le pas sur lui-même c'est
pas qu'on parle c'est c'est une
aberration d'avoir entre guillemets
cette évaluation dans le comparable soit
on en a besoin soit les sociétés
savantes et je parle de lepticure par
exemple dans lequel on a introduit une
demande de prix puisque là aussi on
pourra parler de de la production
française que la production française en
matière première ne fait que augmenter
nous avons des fournisseurs français et
les augmentations sont de l'ordre de
60%, comment va les répercuter on a un
produit dans les tremblements liés aux
Nordiques qui fait 80% du marché mais
quand un comparable qui est totalement
dévoué entre guillemets à des usages
récréatifs qui s'appelle l'artane qui
est moins cher bon et bien on peut pas
avoir de bête de hausse de prix parce
que l'artane est toujours à un euro à 1
euro entre guillemets bon qui se revend
sous le manteau à 10 ou 15 euros et
quelque part cette activité récréative
et le fait que qui perdure sur le marché
fait que vous avez toujours un
comparable qui est moins cher que vous
comment vous faites
c'est absurde cet article 28 dans son
implication dans son écriture est
absurde aujourd'hui je reviens sur sur
les petits si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
de et vous faites un document de 60
pages vous avez 25 pages sur les
génériques 35 pages sur l'innovation
cette page sur les matures et je dis
bien les matures et c'est pas les
critiques il y a pas de page sur les
critiques il y a une page sur les
orphelins mais il y a pas de page sur
les critiques il faut créer
et ça les gaz la bien dit une liste des
critiques pour lequel il faut des
règlements différents
et si on peut aller jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement et c'est aussi vrai en
ville qu'à l'hôpital ce que vous savez
qu'à l'hôpital les prix sont libres
les prix sont libres
et nous on va entreimer amoxicilline à
combien entre 1 euro 80 ça dépend des
marchés 1,80 et 4 euros
l'amoxicilline 1 g injectable alors
qu'on est remboursé en ville 1,09
il y a des absurdités il faut globaliser
pour les critiques
et avoir une vision
anticipatoire parce que le dernier point
que
vous savez que j'ai dit si j'ai la
recette je gagne 12 mois dans la
réintroduction du produit sur le marché
la recette qu'il a c'est une simple
double page d'autorisation de ce référé
un document de recettes et ça c'est le
Big Pharma qui doit nous le donner pour
pouvoir pour faire en sorte de le
réactiver ce produit sinon on repart
comme un générique
alors que le produit en codé tous etc on
repart comme ingénérique et on met trois
ans
aujourd'hui l'amoxicilline solution
buvable pour les pour les enfants avec
entre guillemets une copie d'Aymen
allez c'est 18 mois
sans copie dans les mêmes c'est 3 ans
voilà aujourd'hui il faut qu'on gère les
pénuries dans un premier temps il y a
deux volets
pénurie c'est urgent souveraineté ça va
venir
on peut on peut essayer de faire les
deux progressivement mais la pénurie
aujourd'hui c'est l'hiver prochain qui
est en cause c'est pas
un rapporteur vous voulez poursuivre
votre nom ou répondre chers collègues
est-ce que vous souhaitez prendre la
parole merci Madame la vice-présidente
désolé monsieur schilts je suis arrivé
un peu en retard j'ai pas entendu votre
propos j'étais retenue j'étais revenu
non non mais on allait les comptes
rendus par contre Monsieur Hoffmann vous
nous avez dit qu'il y avait 7000
médicaments thérapeutiques majeurs et
que une des problématiques pour vous
c'est que finalement chaque laboratoire
définit ses propres médicaments donc si
je comprends bien il y a pas de cahier
des charges il y a pas de gris commune
il y a chacun fait sa sauce et vous
pensez que le fait finalement de de
donner une ligne de conduite ou un
cahier des charges à l'ensemble des
médicaments pourrait
peut-être pas solutionner mais aider en
tout cas à sélectionner un certain
nombre de médicaments sur les mêmes
critères finalement
j'irai peut-être pas là jusqu'à là mais
il faudrait à minima harmoniser je vais
je vais vous donner un exemple
sur une de nos spécialités d'amoxiclaves
puisque nous sommes le princeps le
produit s'appelle lève-mantin avant il
s'appelait augmentin nous avons tous les
dosages c'est à dire
le 1 g de gramme le 500 mg nous avons
tous déclaré ces présentations comme
médicament d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur
notre confrère est néanmoins amis
généricur n'a pas fait la même chose sur
l'ensemble de ces gammes c'est à dire
qu'il a un seul dosage qui est déclaré
comme médicament thérapeutique majeur ce
qui fait qu'il n'a pas les mêmes
contraintes en termes de niveau de stock
puisque nous devons avoir 4 mois de
stock pour chacune des présentations
donc voilà je trouve que ça ça
nécessiterait une harmonisation parce
que c'est difficile d'avoir pour un même
médicament de traitement différents
donc voilà donc après oui chacun définit
le niveau d'importance de son médicament
au sein de l'industrie pour chaque
industriel et définit son après son plan
de gestion de risques
mais ces médicaments d'un thérapeutique
majeur il y en a trop tout le monde
n'est pas majeur et c'est là où on dit
qu'il y en a il y a des il y en a qui
sont plus majeurs que d'autres et c'est
là que la notion de médicaments critique
sur un sur un panel de 150 à 200
molécules sur et largement suffisant
et là peut-être qu'on se penche plus sur
le traitement de ces médicaments là
comme le proconiser les gars
et de plus tous travaillent entre
guillemets préparatoires être
présentation d'un plan de gestion de
risque pour les génériques c'est un
travail qui n'a pas d'intérêt c'est
d'avoir cette tendres risque sur un une
seule et même molécule un
antihypertenseur quelconque à cette
prendre de gestion de risque ça n'a pas
de sens ça crée du travail
sans aucune utilité
y a-t-il d'autres informations il nous
reste encore quelques minutes avant de
clôturer ces travaux peut-être vous
vouliez vous avez des propos que le
bonheur ou Madame Mère apporteur moi
peut-être un peu poussé sur crédit impôt
recherche peut-être avoir un peu plus
d'éléments parce que je sais pas si j'ai
bien compris vos propos crédits pour
recherche donc c'est effectivement pour
travailler à la recherche de produits
qui donc son nouveau ça n'est pas votre
ça n'est pas obligatoirement votre
mission alors est-ce que j'ai bien
compris c'est à dire est-ce que pour
vous
ce crédit un pour recherche va vous
permettre de perfectionner des produits
matures donc de les améliorer
éventuellement est-ce que ça ça fait
partie de de cette possibilité de
recherche c'est ma première question ou
est-ce que ce crédit impôt recherche
vous sert à
perfectionner améliorer des chaînes de
de production de fabrication ou les deux
enfin je voilà je mets pas de de
hiérarchie mais pour être sûr d'avoir
bien compris à l'utilisation de ce
crédit pour recherche pour vous
sur le crédit pour recherche en fait
où vous amortiments raison nous ne
faisons pas en soi de la recherche
par contre lorsque nous redéveloppons
from scratch
nouvelle
TIF un actif
qu'il faut totalement redévelopper
y compris redévelopper rechercher des
nouvelles impuretés redévelopper les
méthodes d'analyse afin de permettre de
trouver des impuretés qui n'ont jamais
été chercher
là vous rentrez parfaitement dans le
périmètre du CIL on a été d'ailleurs
plusieurs fois audité
et
ma pourra revenir dessus mais on a eu
plusieurs contrôles d'ailleurs de la
part de l'administration fiscale sur le
CIR jamais on a été redressé d'un seul
euro puisque il est considéré lorsque
vous re développez complètement un
produit chimique
vous pouvez en bénéficier de même rendre
dans le périmètre du crédit pour
recherche toutes les études de stabilité
que vous devez mettre sur pied lorsque
vous re développez un médicament sachant
que dans les conditions ce qu'on appelle
standard
icch vous devez développer trois lots de
validation et que vous devez mettre à
différentes températures et degrés
d'humidité pendant à peu près 2 à 3 ans
ça ça rentre dans le développement et ça
rentre dans le périmètre du crédit pour
recherche mais je peux vous rassurer
nous n'avons pas dépensé 1 euro du
crédit pour recherche qui soit dévoyé
dans d'autres dans d'autres essais
oui pour illustrer le propos
un de nos produits par exemple qu'on a
repris qui était
produit dans la vallée du Rhône
et il y a un comité hygiène et sécurité
qui sont nés un peu
occupés de ce produit puisque les
lavages de ce produit partaient dans le
Rhône et c'était une réaction
exothermique donc il y avait des vapeurs
qui partaient dans l'air il faut savoir
que c'est quand même un anticancéreux
qui est dérivé des gaz de combat de la
Première Guerre mondiale donc on a
récupéré ce produit on a de
re-développer ce produit dans des
conditions de sécurité aujourd'hui les
gens travaillent en scaphandre avec une
pression négative donc il y a plus de
perte et de mise entre guillemets en
risque de l'environnement il faut bien
comprendre que tout tout ça c'est des
éléments de développement et sur ce même
produit il s'avère que était décrit il y
a 40 ans à travers les HPLC en phase
liquide le produit est
une impureté avec maintenant la spectro
de masse nous avons
pour éviter que vous soyez frustré on
n'a pas vraiment répondu à une de vos
questions
qui est le prix du médicament
et sa relation avec les pénuries
je ne pourrais pas répondre pour la
majorité des médicaments je pourrais
simplement vous donner un éclairage sur
les vieux produits sur les produits qui
datent d'avant 2000
produit qui sont toujours importants
dans l'arsenal thérapeutique du médecin
généraliste sachez que la majorité des
prix de ces médicaments
dans le meilleur des cas n'a pas bougé
depuis 2000 donc si vous faites déjà un
index de du coût de la vie entre 2000 et
aujourd'hui sachez que ça correspond
une baisse de 30 %. mais
les différents pfss font qu'il y a eu
des coups de rabot année après année son
qu'on regarde vraiment la situation
les génériqueurs ont fait aussi
beaucoup de mal pour certains moments
une période de l'année période de leur
vie où il y avait des remises énormes et
si laisser penser qu'il y avait beaucoup
si on perdait l'expression d'eau sous la
quille
année après année il y a plus d'eau sous
la quille et maintenant on touche le
muscle c'est même plus grave qu'on
touche le muscle et sur ces vieux
produits là qui n'ont jamais été
revalorisés
il y a plus de marge il y a de la vente
à perte
je sais que vous avez auditionné l'âme
lisse la mise a dû revenir sur ce point
là c'est une réalité il y a beaucoup de
médicaments où il y a beaucoup moins que
20% de marge brut lorsque vous enlevez
après tous les coups de fonctionnement
les taxes qu'on a supporté et les
clauses de sauvegarde vous êtes vous
êtes en vente à perte ce qui n'est pas
acceptable pour ces produits qui sont
pas des innovations de l'année je vous
le connais mais qui sont aujourd'hui des
premiers débits de première ligne en
termes de traitement et faire
disparaître ces produits c'est les faire
remplacer par des produits plus chers
obligatoirement plus cher et ça personne
n'en tient compte donc cette
substitution vers des molécules plus
onéreuses
pour éviter de gagner quelques scènes de
réévaluation de produits anciens c'est
une hérésie
alors oui madame la rapporteur le prix
du médicament ancien et pour beaucoup la
cause de la disparition de ceci
mais quelle mesure vous vous avez envie
de préconiser
pour simplifier justement les démarches
administratives
qui font régner quand même une pesanteur
importante sur toutes les différentes
phases et qui permettraient donc rien
que cette simplification de rendre une
plus grande flexibilité ou la au
laboratoire quel serait quels sont vos
propositions parce que on a quand même
le sentiment au fil des auditions que il
y a beaucoup d'acteurs et d'actrices qui
interviennent de nombreuses agences mais
que quelque part il manque au bout du
bout un pilote dans l'avion si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi de manière un peu
triviale donc qu'est-ce que vous avec
votre expérience vous pourriez proposer
c'est vraiment ma dernière question
votre question est
un peu complexe vous l'imaginez bien
je trouve que en fait depuis 2018 il y a
différentes commissions commissions
d'enquête pénurie des médicaments on n'a
pas touché du doigt on a des facteurs
multiples les facteurs multiples et on
peut pas agir sur tous les facteurs en
même temps
je me suis posé la question Thierry me
l'a posé pourquoi on est convoqué ici je
vous reposer question pourquoi on est
convoqué ici
peut-être parce que et vous l'avez dit
Madame présidente parce qu'on a un
modèle qui pourrait peut-être être
produit
notre modèle prend source entre
guillemets ses idées prend source au
niveau du du site de la NSM dans le
domaine des médicaments en rupture donc
à chaque fois qu'on voit un produit en
rupture donc c'est l'anticipation on va
voir le l'industriel pour lui demander
est-ce que c'est structurel est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est une envie de
s'arrêter est-ce que voilà est-ce que tu
peux pas nous retransmettre ce dossier
il y a il y a entre guillemets une
nécessité d'anticiper et anticiper vous
avez commencé à le faire il faut
reconnaître que les gaz fait bien le
boulot là-dessus il faut
identifier les médicaments critiques
et faire un plan spécifique sur les
médicaments critiques anticiper entre
guillemets où est la propriété
intellectuelle où sont les usines donc
répertoriées les usines de matières
premières
les usines intermédiaires et des usines
de produits finis et à partir de là on
peut faire une cartographie et
intervenir donc il y a besoin entre
guillemets de
d'anticiper les sites de production
bousculés un tout petit peu les Big
Pharma pour qui concède à accepter ce
qu'on appelle une lettre de référence à
leur dossier primaire qui est toute
façon à la NSM donc ça leur prend pas du
temps ça en prend pas de temps il n'y a
pas de risque juridique parce qu'ils ont
tous peur de des risques juridiques de
transférer un dossier parce que il est
peut-être imparfait il est peut-être
incomplet etc là il y a pas de risque
juridique
et ensuite
de suivre entre guillemets ces produits
et ses volumes alors il faut il faut
voir que les volumes qui sont
intéressants à suivre c'est là où vous
avez 1 2 ou 3 acteurs nous on n'est pas
là pour faire du générique on est là
pour s'intéresser à l'acteur avant la
rupture donc pour essayer de sauver et
regarder sur ces produits critiques si
vous avez 5 fournisseurs le problème
n'est pas là si vous avez deux
fournisseurs le problème commence le
problème commence et vous avez l'exemple
il y a pas très longtemps aussi bien en
ville qu'à l'hôpital de l'agent amicine
l'agent amicine et un fournisseur qui
s'est arrêté il y a plus qu'un seul
fournisseur et les acheteurs vous avez
auditionné unis à chaque etc voilà le
prix
multiplié par 10 parce que le prix libre
à l'hôpital
oui je suis en monopole maintenant je
souffre de l'autre côté je vais je vais
je vais essayer de me prendre un peu
dans l'autre côté donc voilà il y a à se
regarder précisément s'il y a
suffisamment de fournisseurs partir de 3
c'est bien à partir de 2 ça devient
dangereux à partir de 1 c'est très
dangereux
et après il faut fixer des des
engagements des engagements aussi
propres de volume et là il n'y achat
fait aussi des travaux intéressants en
faisant des enquêtes auprès des
Américains auprès des Coréens etc en
disant mais il y a des états aux
États-Unis qui ont créé leur propre
usines on a une tentative entre
guillemets juridique normal de dire on a
qu'à se faire de si une reconversion de
ligase d'ailleurs des usines d'État les
usines d'État il en faudrait sans parce
que quand vous faites un antibiotique
vous avez pas le faire un deuxième
antibiotique dans la même usine et vous
pouvez pas remplir une usine que 15
jours par an
ben oui il y a des règles du jeu donc il
y a pas de savoir-faire donc il faut
mettre autour de ça du savoir-faire pour
pour vous diriger c'est vrai que Delbert
on est là probablement parce qu'on a du
savoir-faire
c'est ça qui nous qui nous fait voir
entre guillemets des des médias et de
vous-même ensuite il faudrait pouvoir
anticiper par exemple on vous a pas
parlé des héparines on a travaillé sur
épargne c'est un dossier qu'on a pas
pris parce que
il faudrait qu'on ait un engagement de
prix avant de reprendre le dossier
développer le dossier c'est 10 millions
de d'euros à mettre sur la table
on a quelques discussions vous les cache
pas avec la direction générale de
l'économie des finances il y a pas plus
tard qu'hier en disant mais si on vous
met les 10 millions bah oui mais il faut
que les 10 millions mais que le prix de
remboursement futur soit au-dessus du
péril quand même sinon les diminuant je
vais cramer donc il y a un engagement
dans le temps
ensuite ce que ce que disait uniachat
juste titre c'est que il faut garder un
marché concurrentiel c'est à dire que si
on se garantit 50% du marché c'est déjà
pas mal
sera fournisseur et mettre les autres
entre guillemets en compétition ça peut
être et c'est une réflexion pour rien
vous cacher qu'on a aussi avec une
ihacha parce que on s'intéresse à notre
univers à essayer de le de le sécuriser
l'autre chose après avoir
anticipé que faut-il faire ma sélection
suivante simplifier
simplifier c'est aujourd'hui
simplification de la transmission de cet
ami simplifiée aussi la partie
pharmaceutique du dossier parce qu'il y
a trop il y a trop de temps de relecture
qu'on a un problème sur un produit
critique il faut accélérer il faut qu'on
puisse bénéficier de Fastrac et ça on
peut vous dire que la NSM est très
supportive de de ça sur des médicaments
essentiels ensuite il faut et ça aussi
c'est une source de pénurie on a remis
en place la fausse fourmicine pour y
invocation ça fait deux ans qu'on le
comment n'a pas de promotion il faut
voir que les dernières recommandations
de la spielf fait que a puisqu'on est si
vous lisez le dossier de la SPILF le
produit toujours en rupture
donc on a un problème de communication
et d'accès entre guillemets à
l'information sur le dossier
et si on demande à l'aspire de modifier
dit oui mais nous
on est souvent
voilà donc on a un problème de
communication si c'est sur ces produits
critiques il faut qu'on simplifie parce
que si je dois attendre les six mois de
revues de ma communication pour dire que
le produit est de retour c'est quand
même compliqué au niveau de la NSA
ensuite il faudrait avoir une un
détermination du prix sur une base de
péri transparent c'est jouable c'est
faisable plus
x% et ça aussi c'est la transparence et
Madame elle rapporteuse
zut alors
désolé
ensuite il faudrait comme comme le
montre entre guillemets notre difficulté
sur lithium avoir des processus
accélérés sur les révisions de prix mais
qui peuvent être très contractés
parce que c'est facile une facture c'est
facile à faire passer et ensuite il
faudra avoir des engagements sur la
durée
deux volumes pourquoi parce que nous
même Thierry et moi sommes engagés nos
fournisseurs sur des volumes mini
pendant des années au moins trois ans
avec
un an fixe et si je perds mon marché
hospitalier qui paye pas moi
c'est moi
donc il y a quelque part et moi je vais
pas prendre de risques sur des volumes
plus importants donc je suis toujours en
position de faible charge de mes usines
donc il y a des volumes garantis et
surtout au niveau hospitalier trouver
des volumes garantie comment c'est des
gens en discuter avec unias ensuite
vu le nombre d'acteurs qui qui tourne
autour de ces sujets là il faudrait une
centralisation de la décision parce que
d'aller faire toutes les popotes je peux
vous dire que c'est extrêmement cool et
non merci à présent
merci infiniment pour vos témoignages et
vos précisions qui vont bien sûr
éclairer nos travaux on va devoir
clôturer cette cette audition si vous
restez encore bien sûr des choses à nous
confier je pouvais nous les envoyer par
mail donc si plus personne demande la
parole je propose de lever la séance